I was just swimming swimming but I had  this meeting in the back of my head like  when someone someone bigger than you  stands behind you you get that uneasy  feeling and the hair on the back of the  neck Rises  I had that feeling that something was  going to happen and then I just felt  this thing slam into the side of my body  inside of my Rockley again I just stood  like the bus has hit my right leg now  and I was completely stunned and I  thought to grip onto me and sort of  start shaking me around who pulled me  under the water and I had this sort of  weird out-of-body experience because  shark attacks don't happen to you you  know like just hear about them and then  you kind of know you don't really assist  we don't comprehend with our bills you  know I don't think anyone can and I  think anyone should I try to push the  shock off my leg